hahahaha what a weird beginning for a
video that's titled though hi guys my
name is grace Helbig know now you know
you're like a different now I could not
think of a video idea that I wanted to
post today and I realized a lot of the
reason I couldn't just allow myself to
think clearly was because I'm feeling a
little prat and spoiler alert this
happens to me kind of frequently and as
Mozilla talked to some professionals and
that can identify it and it's okay and
everything's fine and it's normal but
hey why don't we just embrace this and
make this video I've been managing my
own anxiety and whatever feelings for
years and years now so I thought hey
let's use this video as a way to show
you guys things I've learned over the
years that helped me calm the bad I like
to engage in passive creative activities
for me that's cooking but then I realize
that I'm not cooking I'm just using this
activity to avoid my inbox and
unanswered calls from family members and
loved ones and then I just
another tactic I use watching reality
television I love it I think it's so
dumb and so fun until I realize that
perhaps I'm using it as a tool to watch
people that I subconsciously think are
in deeper pain than I am and then I just
another major tactic is playing with my
dog who gives me nothing but pure love
energy because she thinks that her job
is just to love me and it's absolutely
amazing until I realized that I
voluntarily linked myself up with
something I would likely outlive and
then I just
sometimes I get my hair makeup to feel
better and then I realized the fleeting
side of vanity because my body is a
vessel for my personality it doesn't
actually represent Who I am or what
legacy I want to leave because it will
decline rapidly and then I just
sometimes I like to read very
intellectually inspiring books that have
been recommended on Instagram before I
realized that the person that
recommended to some Instagram and also
myself are just trying to seem cool by
association rather than actually taking
into thought I need the intellectual
inspiring material inside the book and
then I just
exercise my number one go-to for any
sort of anxiety that I am experiencing
until I realized that I'm alone with my
thoughts and what am I actually running
from metaphorically not physically and
then yes
well there you go there are a few ways
that I manage my personal anxiety and
depression if you liked this video give
it a thumbs up don't forget to subscribe
to my youtube channel make videos Monday
Wednesday and Friday infrequently and
list the Beeman's in the head go out to
play I don't know I think we got that
one